Imagine two people who share an important secret
have to split up.
This requires them to communicate
private information from a distance.
However, an eavesdropper named Eve
also wants this information,
and has the ability to intercept their messages.
So, Alice decides to communicate
using letters written in some kind of secret code.
The following analogy is helpful.
First, Alice locks her message in a box,
using a lock that only she and Bob
know the combination to.
This is known as 'encryption.'
Then, the locked message is sent to Bob.
When Bob receives the box, he opens it
using the code they shared in advance.
This is called 'decryption.'
Cryptography begins when we abandon physical locks
and use 'ciphers' instead.
Think of [ciphers] as virtual locks.
Ciphers allow Alice and Bob to scramble
and descramble their messages
so that they would appear meaningless
if Eve intercepted them.
Cryptography has been around for thousands of years.
It has decided wars, and is at the heart of
the worldwide communication network today.
The fascinating story of cryptography
requires us to understand two very old ideas
related to number theory and probability theory.